[Music]
okay
sexy thoughts we free waffles did i just
say that out loud
what sorry just a second
[Music]
what i forgot at the store i couldn't
remember all day i'm ready now
i don't think you are just admit you're
not into sex
it's kind of like you're pornophobic try
saying something
racing you need to decide it's me or the
porn
[Music]
i want your hot throbbing
[Music]
you right love just coming to check to
make sure everything's fine
what what no no no i'm just medicating
meditating
hello wait why do you look so good i met
someone so
i made a sex to-do list best breakup
ever
[Music]
quick question for you do you do pilates
or
oh wow do you know what you really have
turned over a new leaf
get a dance don't you think he's a
little bit out of my league you're just
afraid to get back on the horse
it's like riding a bike or maybe a pogo
stick
[Music]
it's like one ghost and you're my
patrick swayze
okay tell me everything i need to know
about you sure you want to know
yeah you're right it could be the end of
something good before it even starts
or it could be the start of something
good that doesn't end
that is corny
i just want to find out if this works
actually sir
i've got it on right now what do you
mean you're wearing it now
ah loose i don't think you put erection
cream on your lips
[Music]
you